when parts of the human body break down
or are damaged options are limited
scientists are working on providing
replacement parts on demand like fingers
ears and bladders laboratory engineered
bladders have already been successfully
implanted in humans the stuff of science
fiction may soon be a reality
[Music]
they begin with a mold a finger mold on
the right and an ear on the left
these molds can be made of synthetic
polymers or natural materials such as
collagen
scientists will grow real cells on the
molds
to obtain those cells a scientist first
extracts a small piece of cartilage
which is a type of connective tissue in
the body she chops it into little bits
she transfers the minced cartilage to a
test tube partially filled with a
special enzyme this enzyme dissolves
tissue leaving only the cartilage cells
she then places the test tube in a
centrifuge for a high speed spin
this causes the cartilage cells to
separate from the enzyme solution and
settle on the bottom
she siphons off the liquid and the tiny
cells remain in the test tube
next she adds a red liquid it's a
culture medium it will act as a
fertilizer to stimulate cell growth
transferred to a petri dish she swishes
the mix to dispense the cells
then it's into an incubator warmed to
98.6 degrees fahrenheit body temperature
it's the perfect environment to spur
more cell growth
meanwhile a computer-controlled machine
builds the mold of the ear
it layers synthetic polymer to produce
an authentic looking shape
this process takes about five hours
in the meantime the microscopic cells
have multiplied 20 times
the scientist drips them on to the
completed mold where they continue to
grow
in the future cell-covered ear molds
could be implanted under a patient's
skin
cartilage would form and the body would
accept the part as its own
other scientists are working on growing
blood vessels and heart valves
they start by extracting a type of stem
cell from human blood
the researcher first fills a test tube
with the clear high density solution
he adds diluted blood to the clear
solution
almost instantly the different
components of the blood begin to
separate
the heavier red blood cells plummet and
the lighter stem cells rise to the top
of the test tube
a spin in the centrifuge leaves the
components visibly separated
allowing scientists to retrieve the
desired cells
they'll convert them to endothelial
cells which line the inside of blood
vessels and heart valves
in the meantime they construct the blood
vessel mold
the scientists add solvent to liquid
collagen causing it to instantly
dissolve
he adds little white beads their
synthetic polymers
and they liquefy over a period of about
an hour
they spray the collagen concoction onto
a rod that spins as a carriage moves it
to and fro for even coverage
the collagen and polymer mixture quickly
solidifies around the rod
the scientist slides off the now
hardened biomaterial
he now has a mold for shaping a human
blood vessel
he coats the mold with the microscopic
endothelial cells which by now have
grown and multiplied
he then pumps fluid through it to
simulate blood flow this conditions the
cells to go with the flow and
collectively operate as a real blood
vessel
to grow a heart valve they don't
actually build a mold they use a real
valve from a pig
the scientist plunges the pig valve into
a container filled with a mild detergent
it goes into a machine that shakes it up
the agitation helps scrub off the cells
leaving only the valve skeleton
he saturates the valve skeleton with
human cells where they grow and thrive
the research team then pumps fluid
through the valve just like they did
with the blood vessel
this trains the cells to do the work
they would need to do in the human body
even dr frankenstein would be impressed
[Music]
you